TO THE END OF THE COLD WAR.
MATTHEW CHANCE LOOKS BACK AT HIS
LIFE AND IMPACT ON RUSSIA AND
THE WORLD.
>> WITH THAT PORT STAIN BIRTH
MARK ON HIS FOREHEAD, MIKHAIL
GORBACHEV WAS ONE OF THE MOST
RECOGNIZABLE FIGURES IN 20th
CENTURY POLITICS.
HIS ATTEMPTS TO REFORM THE
SOVIET UNION AND HIS ROLE IN
ENDING THE COLD WAR MADE HIM ONE
OF ITS MOST INFLUENTIAL TOO.
AS A YOUNG MAN, GORBACHEV
STUDIED LAW AT MOSCOW STATE
UNIVERSITY.
IT'S THERE HE MET AND MARRIED A
FELLOW STUDENT.
HE WENT ON TO FORGE A CAREER IN
THE COMMUNIST PARTY, EVENTUALLY
AGE 54 BECOMING ITS GENERAL
SECRETARY, THE LEADER OF HAD
SOVIET UNION.
IT WAS IN THIS ROLE THAT
GORBACHEV AND HIS WIFE BROKE THE
MOLD.
HE FOR HIS OUTGOING CHARISMATIC
NATURE.
SHE FOR HER STYLISH OUTFITS AND
ELEGANCE SHE BROUGHT TO THE ROLE
OF SOVIET FIRST LADY.
BUT THE VAST COMMUNIST NATION
THEY RULED WAS ON THE BRINK OF
CRISIS.
AMID SHORTAGES OF FOOD AND
CONSUMER GOODS, THE SOVIET
COMMAND ECONOMY WAS GRINDING TO
A HALT.
THERE WAS ALSO ALARM AT THE
APPARENTLY SLOW RESPONSE TO THE
SOVIET AUTHORITIES TO THE
NUCLEAR DISASTER AT CHERNOBYL.
GORBACHEV TRIED TO FIX THINGS
WITH WHAT HE CALLED PARIS
STRIKER, REFORMS THAT WERE TO
REVOLUTIONIZE THE SOVIET SYSTEM.
>> I BEGAN THESE REFORMS AND MY
GUIDING STARS WERE FREEDOM AND
DEMOCRACY.
WITHOUT BLOODSHED.
SO THE PEOPLE WOULD CEASE TO BE
HEARD LED BY A SHEPHERD.
THEY WOULD BECOME CITIZENS.
>> THE WAS REVOLUTION, TOO, IN
RELATIONS WITH THE WEST.
FACE-TO-FACE WITH U.S. PRESIDENT
RONALD REAGAN, GORBACHEV MADE A
STUNNING PROPOSAL, TO ELIMINATE
ALL NUCLEAR MISSILES HELD BY THE
TWO SUPERPOWERS.
IT WAS THE BEGINNING OF THE END
OF THE COLD WAR.
SOON THE BERLIN WALL WOULD FALL.
AND AFTER A FAILED COUP BY HARD
LINERS IN MOSCOW, THE SOVIET
UNION ITSELF WAS DISSOLVED, AND
GORBACHEV RESIGNED.
>> I HEREBY DISCONTINUE MY
ACTIVITIES AT THE POST OF
PRESIDENT OF THE USSR.
>> IN 1999, HE LOST THE LOVE OF
HIS LIFE.
HIS WIFE OF 46 YEARS, WHO DIED
OF LEUKEMIA.
BUT THERE WAS NO LOVE LOST
BETWEEN MANY RUSSIANS AND
GORBACHEV.
TO MANY OF HIS COUNTRYMEN, HE
WOULD ALWAYS BE THE MAN WHO
ALLOWED THE GREAT SOVIET EMPIRE
TO COLLAPSE, EXPOSING MILLIONS
TO HARDSHIP AND HUMILIATION.
EVEN GORBACHEV HIMSELF EXPRESSED
REGRET.
>> I FOUGHT THE BEST I COULD TO
DEFEND THE SOVIET UNION.
BUT I FAILED.
>> IN THE WEST, HE WAS REVERED
AND CELEBRATED AS A GREAT
STATESMAN.
A NOBEL PEACE PRIZE WINNER WHO
PLAYED A DECISIVE ROLE IN ENDING
THE COLD WAR, PEACEFULLY
DIFFUSING THE MOST DANGEROUS
STANDOFF OF THE 20th SERVERY.
>> OUR THANKS TO MATTHEW CHANCE
FOR THAT REPORTING.
I WANT TO BRING IN JILL
DOUGHERTY, THE FORMER CNN MOSCOW
BUREAU CHIEF.
THANK YOU FOR SPENDING TIME WITH
US.
GORBACHEV WAS SUCH AN EXTREMELY
INFLUENTIAL POLITICIAN AND
LEADER IN RUSSIAN HISTORY.
YOU LIVED IN RUSSIA FOR ABOUT A
DECADE.
YOU MET GORBACHEV SEVERAL TIMES.
HOW -- WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION
WHEN YOU HEARD HE PASSED?
>> YOU KNOW, INTENSE SADNESS,
REALLY, BECAUSE GORBACHEV, I
THINK, IN CONTRAST TO ANY
PREVIOUS SOVIET LEADER, WAS A
PERSONAL LEADER.
HE HAD EXTRAORDINARY CHARISMA.
AND JUST ON A PERSONAL BASIS,
INTERVIEWING HIM, MEETING HIM,
AND ALSO HIS RELATIONSHIP WHICH
MATTHEW MENTIONED, WITH HIS
WIFE.
HE BROKE THE MOLD WHEN IT CAME
TO AN APPROACHABLE, PERSONABLE
LEADER, AND THAT, NOT TO
MENTION, OF COURSE, HIS ROLE IN
HISTORY, WHICH WAS ENORMOUS.
IF YOU JUST LOOK AT THE SOVIET
UNION ITSELF, AND HOW HE CHANGED
THAT, HE CHANGED IT WITH
OPENNESS AND ALL OF A SUDDEN,
PUBLICATIONS THAT NOBODY COULD
EVER READ BEFORE, THEY WERE ALL
OVER THE PLACE.
PEOPLE WERE READING FORBIDDEN
LITERATURE BECAUSE THERE WAS AN
INTELLECTUAL OPENING AND A
SOCIAL OPENING, AND PERESTROIKA
MEANS REBUILDING, AND WHAT HE
WANTED TO DO, AND THIS IS WHERE
HE FAILED, IS TO KEEP THE SOVIET
UNION GOING.
HE BELIEVED YOU COULD REFORM IT,
TURN IT INTO SOMETHING LIKE
MAYBE EUROPEAN SOCIALISM, BUT
THAT WAS IMPOSSIBLE.
AND YOU KNOW, THE SOVIET UNION
COLLAPSED.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT, WHEN PEOPLE
REALLY BEGAN TO LIVE EXTREMELY
HARD LIVES, THE ECONOMY FELL
APART, THERE WAS NO STRUCTURE
LEFT ANYMORE TO THE ECONOMY OR
EVEN SOCIETALLY, PEOPLE BEGAN TO
BLAME HIM.
AND TO THIS DAY, MANY RUSSIANS
REVILE HIM.
SO TO ME, HE IS THE PERSON WHO
ABSOLUTELY CHANGED HISTORY WITH
HIS OWN PERSONALITY, TO HAVE
THAT VISION THAT SOMEHOW THINGS
COULD CHANGE.
AND IT DIDN'T WORK OUT THE WAY
HE WANTED IT TO, BUT HE
CERTAINLY WILL GO DOWN IN
HISTORY AS A PERSON WHO REALLY
REFORMED AND BROUGHT RUSSIA OUT
OF THE DARKNESS, INTO WHAT
EVENTUALLY BECAME SOME TYPE OF
DEMOCRACY.
WE KNOW THE PROBLEMS THAT EXIST
RIGHT NOW, BUT GORBACHEV
CERTAINLY, I WOULD HOPE THAT
RUSSIANS EVENTUALLY, MANY YEARS
FROM NOW, WILL REMEMBER HIM AS A
PERSON WHO ACTUALLY IMPROVED
RUSSIA AND SAVED RUSSIA FROM
ITSELF AT MANY MOMENTS.
>> CERTAINLY SOMEONE WHO
IMPROVED THE WORLD.
JILL, STAND BY FOR ME, PLEASE.
I WANT TO BRING IN CNN'S FRED
PLEITGEN IN MOSCOW.
FRED, WHAT IS THE REACTION IN
RUSSIA TO THE NEWS?
>> HI, THERE.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY JUST DROPPING
HERE IN RUSSIAN NEWS AGENCIES,
AND REALLY SO FAR, WHAT WE'RE
GETTING IS A MESSAGE FROM THE
HOSPITAL WHERE MIGUEL GORBACHEV
WAS BEING TREATED WHEN SIMPLY
SAID, I'M TRANSLATING THIS AS I
GO, TONIGHT, THIS EVENING, AFTER
A VERY PROLONGED AND VERY SEVERE
ILLNESS, MIKHAIL GORBACHEV HAS
DIED.
THAT'S SO FAR ALL WE HAVE FROM
THE HOSPITAL ITSELF.
OBVIOUSLY REACHING OUT TO
VARIOUS GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
IT'S ALREADY PRETTY LATE HERE IN
MOSCOW, BUT JILL IS OBVIOUSLY
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE HERE IN RUSSIA
WILL OBVIOUSLY BE VERY SAD
TONIGHT, WILL BE MOURNING
TONIGHT, BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
GORBACHEV DID HAVE A MIXED BAG
OF RESULTS FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE
HERE IN THIS COUNTRY AND IS NOT
SOMEONE WHO NECESSARILY HAS BEEN
A POPULAR FIGURE HERE OVER THE
PAST COUPLE OF YEARS, OVER THE
PAST COUPLE DECADES.
MANY OF COURSE SAYING HE WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE ENDS OF THE
SOVIET UNION AND MANY PEOPLE
FEEL IT'S SORT OF BROUGHT THIS
COUNTRY INTO A CHAOS THAT IT
TOOK A LONG TIME FOR THE COUNTRY
TO RECOVER FROM.
SO WHEN YOU SPEAK TO PEOPLE HERE
ON THE STREETS IN MOSCOW AND
OTHER RUSSIAN CITIES, YOU WON'T
NECESSARILY HEAR VERY KIND WORDS
ABOUT MIKHAIL GORBACHEV.
YOU WON'T NECESSARILY HEAR A LOT
OF PEOPLE WITH A LOT OF SYMPATHY
FOR MIKHAIL GORBACHEV, BUT I
THINK JILL IS ABSOLUTELY CORRECT
TO SAY OBVIOUSLY HE BROUGHT THE
THEN SOVIET UNION INTO A WHOLE
DIFFERENT PATH, A WHOLE NEW ERA.
AND ALSO, ONE OF THE THINGS WE
HAVE TO POINT OUT WITH MIKHAIL
GORBACHEV IS WHILE HE WASN'T
NECESSARILY VERY POPULAR HERE IN
RUSSIA, ESPECIALLY DURING THE
PUTIN ERA AND DURING THE 1990s,
WHEN A LOT OF THE -- WHICH LIFE
BECAME VERY DIFFICULT FOR A LOT
OF PEOPLE, A LOT OF
DISORDERLINESS HERE IN MOSCOW
AND OTHER CITIES, BUT IF YOU
LOOK, FOR INSTANCE, TOWARDS
EUROPE, OBVIOUSLY HE'S SOMEONE
WHO IS ABSOLUTELY ADORED THERE.
YOU LOOK FOR INSTANCE AT GERMANY
WHERE HE IS STILL VERY MUCH
REVERED BY A LOT OF PEOPLE.
HE LIVED IN GERMANY FOR AN
EXTENDED PERIOD OF TIME, AND
MANY PEOPLE BELIEVE HE WAS
LARGELY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
UNIFICATION OF EUROPE, TOGETHER
WI